loving the energy welcome to the next
level people I want you to say hello to
tonight's comedians I'm talking about my
guy
Malik s who comes to us from Miami
Florida come on man get a guy's in love
let's talk about you teach and I heard
you teach English teacher we're great in
eighth grade 6 and 8th grade yeah yeah
yeah yeah successful teacher like us not
really
substitute teacher oh no real teacher a
real teacher for a year
we're not a whole year we went to spring
break you know to get that week off yeah
I ain't go back you know the crazy thing
is you know spring breeze kind of like
like April school isn't like May June
so I had enough sick time to take off
for the rest of the year he's not coming
back I really still had a job but I was
just like I'm sick ok I saw this picture
and I just wanna I want to ask the
people who their thing I'm gonna show
you guys man
what Malik looked like when he was
teaching this is this would look like
but isn't this in Miami Florida no and
there's this 2003 - you gotta think like
that was the look about how did you go
from here to there because they kept
backing it up so it was like I was gonna
have a convertible dream so I'll just
say you know what
[Music]